willkommen zur aktuellen vorlesung heute
geht es um die ethik der digitalität und
den ersten teil dieses größeren
bereiches und ganz speziell um das
internet als
handlungsraum
hier ist noch viel zu entwickeln das
internet hatten wir schon in einer
sitzung behandelt unter dem
gesichtspunkt der erkenntnistheorie der
systeme bis zum szenischen bedeutung der
psychologie der digitalität dann mache
ich auch oben rechts ein link rahn den
direkten verweisung slink aber heute
soll es über das internet gehen und der
spezifisch praktischen gesichtspunkten
unter der fragestellung inwiefern wir
nicht nur durch das internet kennen
sondern inwiefern wir auch durch das
internet handeln also heute steht die
praktische dimension der digitalität am
beispiel des internets im zentrum
ja was ist der plan der heutige
vorlesung zunächst mal gebe ich noch mal
einen rückblick auf die letzte sitzung
auf die chronologie die raumzeit der
digitalität die frage wie wir virtuelle
digitale realität entspreche jetzt hier
im folgen die man nur von virtuellen
digitalen realität nicht von virtuellen
realitäten die sonst noch gibt wie zum
beispiel geld wie wir diese digitalen
realitäten mit blick auf raumzeit
verstehen können dann gehe ich auf das
eigentliche thema der heutigen sitzung
ein nämlich auf das internet dass ich
unter dem gesichtspunkt des sozialen
handlungsraum verstehe und dann gibt es
am schluss einen kurzen ausblick auf die
nächste sitzung
in dem wieder die ethische dimension
behandelte der digitalität diesmal aber
am beispiel von künstlichen intelligenz
auch nicht aus ästhetische dimension wie
wir ist schon haben
genau jetzt hatten wir hier schon der
letzten sitzung etwas die thematik
angefangen wie wird die räumlichkeit der
digitalen wird schon realität verstehen
können
virtuelle realitäten und da gibt es eine
große diskussion darüber digitale
virtuelle realität
existieren jedenfalls nicht so in raum
und zeit wie es jetzt irgendwelche
physischen dinge tun des alltäglichen
lebens wie bücher im regal die mit der
zeit vergeben oder andere beliebige
gegenstände auch wie wir selbst
aber wir müssen natürlich dazu sagen
virtuelle realitäten digitale virtuelle
realitäten existieren natürlich nicht
mit irgendeiner neben welt in einem über
himmlische nord wie platon sagen würde
über seine ideen diesen ideen himmel so
sollten wir uns digitale virtuelle
realitäten meines erachtens nicht
vorstellen das zeug falsche hoffnungen
falsche erwartungen an die möglichkeiten
digitaler virtuelle realität also hier
kann man sehr schnell abdriften in
solche futuro list
futuristischen
ideologien wie zum beispiel von
den kann wie ray kurzweil die eben von
einer singularität sprechen mache ich
auch oben rechts in den grenzen der
ersten sitzung wo wir auf diese
spekulation eingegangen sind also wenn
wir jetzt davon sprechen dass virtuelle
realitäten nicht unser herkömmlichen
rauben zeit logik folgen das würde ich
vertreten dann heißt es nicht dass da
eine neue welt eine gegenwelt in diesem
sinne entsteht dass sie in konkurrenz
tritt zur physischen welt dass wir hier
irgendwie unsterblich werden können dass
wir unser gehirn unsere subjektivität in
die cloud hochladen können das ist da
ist damit überhaupt nicht gemeint ist
viel banaler viel alltäglicher für
lebensweltliche was ich glaube was es
mit digitaler virtuelle realität auf
sich hat ich würde auch sagen digitale
virtuelle realitäten sollten wir uns
nicht im sinne von einer zweiten stufe
die über der herkömmlichen stufe wie
losgelöst vor sich hin existiert
verstehen sondern eher im sinne dieser
an diese nahtlose
integration an unsere physische melde
ich glaube ist so müssen wir das ganze
verstehen und da werden dann ganz viele
ideologische position schon nicht mehr
relevant damit es gebe ich ein paar
beispiele habe ich das letzte mal schon
gemacht online guthaben gegenstände
inside virtuelle gegenstände zum
beispiel auch wikipedia wieder mein
lieblingsbeispiel das existiert
irgendwie raum und zeitlos aber auch
irgendwie wiederum ist es von raum zeit
abhängig das ist ja unbestritten es muss
irgendwo mit einem server zusammenhängen
irgendwoher muss es die energie bekommt
diese struktur also ganz unabhängig
existiert es nicht aber wir können das
ist meine these auch nicht einfach
reduzieren auf die serverstruktur auf
die software die dahinter steht das wäre
wiederum zu wenig realität die wir der
virtuellen realität zugestehen würde
müssen als ein ausgeglichenes verhältnis
denken ich habe es einmal in dieser
sitzung über virtuelle realität versucht
zu zeigen mit der konstitution relation
von lynn baker die das am beispiel des
geldes macht der banknote also das
papier das die banknote ausmacht das
konstituiert das papiergeld das heißt es
ist die basis die materielle basis und
darauf reagiert dann die virtuelle
realität des geldes nicht nur dank
dieser papier grundlage sonst könnte ich
ja jedes beliebige papier nehmen dann
werd aufschreiben und schade ist seiner
banknote wird mit der ich was einkaufen
kann sondern natürlich anhand von
relationalen eigenschaften die damit
dazu kommen müsse zum beispiel eine
gesellschaft die diesen wert garantiert
institutionen wie eine zentralbank aber
natürlich auch relationen die stabil
sind zu anderen wert nach geld ist ja
nicht nur etwas einseitig rationales da
gibt es ganz viele abhängigkeiten die
mit hineinspielen diese ganzen
abhängigkeit muss damit er zu nehmen das
haben wir diesen papier und dann
reagiert darauf diese virtuelle realität
des scans und ganz ähnlich glaube ich
können wir das auch uns so denken wie im
beispiel von
digitalen virtuellen realitäten und auf
dieser basis können wir dann natürlich
nur adäquate gedanken machen über die
praktische bedeutung von virtuellen
digitalen realität
das heißt noch ein wichtiger punkt der
dazukommt ist virtuelle gegenstände ich
spreche natürlich immer von digitalen
virtuellen gegenständen die sind durch
eine super leitfähigkeit und
reibungslose miteinander verbunden und
die verdankt sich natürlich der
digitalen technik das ist ganz klar gar
keine frage so was wie
lichtgeschwindigkeit was die
physikalische größen auch wie
widerstände usw die spielen da eine
rolle die sind die basis dafür dass so
eine technologie auch virtuelle realität
werden kann das ist unbestritten es gibt
damit ganz ganz grosse tiefen schicht
dahinter unter wie auch immer man sich
das jetzt metaphorischen feststelle
vorstellen möchte das existiert nicht
einfach losgelöst von technik die
technik muss immer mit dazu kommen wie
auch immer das zu uns jetzt hier im
seminar nicht interessieren wir sind
hier eine philosophische veranstalten
und das kann man gern den
informatikerinnen und informatikern im
detail überlassen uns interessiert nicht
so sehr die technische das ist das was
auf dieser basis reagiert was da an
sozialen und ökologischen
epidemiologischen finden auftritt die
wir erst noch adäquat beschreiben müssen
hier kommen wir philosophin und
philosophen spielt die adäquaten
begriffe für diesen neuen realitäten zu
prägen und sie nicht nur als technische
phänomene zu begreifen die dann
vielleicht sogar noch irgendwie
gefährlich sind oder sucht und so weiter
provozieren jetzt ist es so diese super
leitfähigkeit die zb das internet groß
zeichnet also gegenstände oder auch
sonstige dinge im internet die sind
ziemlich leicht miteinander zu
verknüpfen ich musste nicht von einem
ort zum anderen tagen das braucht
räumliche distanz die zurückgelegt
werden muss und natürlich auch zeitliche
distanz das braucht immer zeit jetzt
kann man sich fragen ist jetzt diese
reibungslose kite im virtuellen raum des
internets ist jetzt nur so eine
eigenschaft eines dinges wie zb sein
gewicht in physischer hinsicht oder
seine dateigröße digitaler hinsicht ich
glaube nein ich glaube die reibungslose
sich kyte ist nicht nur eine
unwesentliche eigenschaft kann akzidenz
welche farbe hat das ding der digitalen
virtuellen realität sondern es ist ein
wesensmerkmal welches gewichtigen
theologische und auch ethische darauf
sollen wir ja heute zu sprechen kommt
implikationen hat also hemmungslosigkeit
uns nichts der der virtuellen realität
die digitale virtuelle realität
äußerlich ist etwas innerliches etwas
was die struktur digitaler virtuelle
realität schreibt ohne die wir die
ganzen phänomene so meine thesen nicht
adäquat
beschreiben können und jetzt werde ich
ein bisschen konkreter was mal diese
reibungslosen ich kite diese
reibungslose ich kein meint dass die
relationen in den virtuellen realitäten
stehen digitalen raum dass die auf eine
andere weise zu denken sind als relation
im physischen physikalischen zeitlichen
raum sind relationen sind im digitalen
virtuellen raum etwas viel leichteres
etwas viel normaler das sag ich mal auch
etwas viel unmittelbares und diese
unmittelbarkeit der relation alle der
beziehung zwischen anderen objekten
natürlich auch zwischen anderen personen
da kommen dann am ende holt noch darauf
zu sprechen
anonymen person oder pseudonym person
avataren wie auch immer diese relation
sind einfach von viel intimere art als
relation im physischen zeitlichen raum
sind und das hat natürlich auch wieder
auswirkungen auf die ethik im virtuellen
raum wenn relationen auf eine viel
intimere weise nämlich reibungslos zu
denken
also das ist ein plädoyer für eine
veränderte auffassung von reibungslose
ich kein reibungsloser keiten zeitlichen
sinne reibungslos ich kai timm
räumlichen sinne und das unter dem
gesichtspunkt der relation die im
digitalen virtuellen raum eine
grundlegende bedeutung hat ohne die wir
überhaupt nicht diese phänomene bestehen
verstehen können ich würde sagen diese
raum zeitliche reibungslos ich kann
diese relation irrt hat ist der rahmen
die rahmenbedingungen unter der wir
überhaupt diese ganzen dinge nur
angemessen verstehen können jetzt komme
ich nochmal ein bisschen auf die zeit
der digitalität zu sprechen ich hatte
schon der letzten sitzung gesagt dass
virtuelle digitale realitäten keine
sukzessiven zeit logik folgen zumindest
nicht wesentlich folgen das muss ich
vielleicht noch ein bisschen
einschränken an im anschluss an die
letzte diskussion sind dass ihre
gegenstände die virtuellen digital
gegenstände ubiquitär präsent sind kann
von einer ub präsent sprechen ubiquity
heißt überall zur gleichen zeit zum
beispiel zugänglich sind oder geltung
wie auch immer die präsenz warum auch
wegen dieser
reibungslosen kite die dort herrscht die
ordnung der virtuellen realität der
digitalen ist nicht primär sagt jetzt
deswegen primär weil es natürlich auch
noch einen anderen sinn geht nicht
primär
sukzessiv deutlich zu verstehen sondern
vielmehr logisch zuletzt in logischen
vernetzung wir kommen gleich nochmal
auszusprechen zählt der zeitlich
sukzessiv aspekt nicht mehr so eine
wichtige wollen wir könnten zwar auch
abheben isolieren wir können virtuelle
digitalität unter dem gesichtspunkt von
zeitlicher sukzession betrachten aber
diese betrachtungsweise ist keine
betrachtungsweise die gänge ihrer
eigentlichen existenzform betrifft
sondern eher eine äußerliche
betrachtungsweise eine metadaten
betrachtungsweise wie ich noch genauer
erläutern werde
die zeit so hatte ich die letzten
sitzung versucht zu analysieren oder
genauer zu beschreiben entspricht der
zeitlosen zerai von john mc tageszeit
türige zeit der digitalität die zeit der
virtuelle daten oder auch realität die
zeit der digitalität ist keine
chronologische also sukzessive zeit sind
eine logische zeit oder eine relationale
zeit und hier mit der relation kommt
wieder die raum zeitliche reibungslose
ich kite ins spiel die vor allem dem
internet zu grunde liegt jetzt möchte
ich nochmal hier kurz diese drei reihen
nach mctaggart kurz vorstellen da habe
ich ein paar grafiken entwickelt die
glaube ich dass ganzjährig deutlich
veranschaulichen können das ist nochmal
die arbeit meint es gibt verschiedene
ereignisse im zeitstrahl der sich
erstreckt von links nach rechts
m n o p q r s und soweit es gibt keine
reihenfolge und diese reihenfolge von
verschiedenen ereignissen sind ist
zeitlich zu verstehen wenn der jetzt
aber so dass es ereignisse gibt die noch
nicht sind und ereignisse die gibt die
schon waren weil wir uns in diesem jetzt
punkt befinden der durch das ereignis in
gekennzeichnet ist aus der sicht von m
war ihm schon gewesen ist schon
vergangen und kommt nur auf uns zu beide
module sind aber noch nicht aktuell real
zum vergangen und zukünftig als die
arbeit derzeit die ist die in
mexikanische reihe in mexikanischem eine
solche wörter wie jetzt und hier ja so
hinweisende zug nahmen die sich
natürlich ändern können je nachdem wo
ich bin da bin ich sage hier
sage dass hier dann bin ich jetzt hier
gerade zum beispiel münchen wenn ich
hier der schweiz sage dann bin ich hier
in der schweiz also je nach das hängt
immer vom kontext ab wo ich das jetzt
sage natürlich jetzt hier und jetzt
bezieht sich erfreuliche kontext der
zeitlichen kontext wie wir ihn jetzt
natürlich nur von zeitlichen kontext
jetzt gibt es die b 33 kann man sich so
vorstellen dass sie abstrahiert von der
arbeit die abstrahiert insofern davon
als sie diese index ik lische bezugnahme
ausblendet und hier spielt es keine
rolle mehr wo das jetzt ist sondern hier
spielt männer eine rolle von früher und
später von ereignissen weise war vor
etwa verloren das heißt m ist früher als
erst oder anders formuliert
ist später oder jünger also jünger und
so ist wie man
das ist die beere hier geht's also
vorher nachher für
spekulationen mich und das war es jetzt
ist hier wird die subjektivität
ausgeblendet hier spielt es keine rolle
wo sich das objekt befindet das subjekt
befindet sich gewissermaßen über einer
zeit weil es die ganzen zeitlichen
ereignisse überblickt deswegen spricht
man hier auch von präsentismus oder auch
idealismus weil er eben alles vor uns
ausgebreitet und wir nicht mehr in der
zeit gewesen laden sind sondern
außerhalb der zeit aber so dass die zeit
die sukzession immer noch verfolgen also
jetzt deuten immer wir sind in der zeit
seien bestimmt zeitpunkt und die zeit
läuft durch und durch in den reihen der
bereich
sehen wir die zeit punkte aufgereiht wie
auf einer perle vor und so kann man sich
leicht vorstellen und nach der arbeit
würde die perle immer weiter
durch gesten den faden rolle aber es
geht eben nur eine perle das wäre jetzt
nur das jetzt nur ein zeitpunkt er das
jetzt und hier bei der bereich sind alle
zeit punkte vor mehr ausgebreitet aber
eben immer noch in der relation der
sukzession dass wir eben nie dann sagen
kann im war nach
oder in war nach soll die reihenfolge
bleibt hier bestehen nur nicht mehr
unter dem gesichtspunkt dass jetzt
und jetzt können wir noch weiter
abstrahieren fand dieser zeit drei
nämlich die wir der dem wir diese folge
diesen teil überhaupt aufheben und nur
noch eine logische reihung von
ereignissen oder verhältnissen denken
dass hier kann man jetzt nicht mehr
sagen in folgt auf mtu folgt auf oder im
gingen voraus sondern hier in zeitlicher
hinsicht muss man sagen hier folgt das
irgendwie aufeinander aber eben nicht
mehr zeitlich sie stehen in einer
relation die irgendwie gefestigt ist die
bestimmt ist aber sie ist nicht zeitlich
bestimmt nicht zu passiv bestimmt und
mir scheint jetzt dass wir wenn wir hier
eben philosophische theorien anwenden
wollen auf die raumzeit logik der
digitalität wir hier besonders die cera
in betracht ziehen müssen das heißt
jetzt nicht dass im internet nicht auch
dinge aufeinander folgen ohne frage
erfolgen hätte ihn ja aufeinander aber
ich glaube dass die realität form die
präsentationsweise wie sich realitäten
virtuelle realität uns digital
präsentieren das die sich nicht so sehr
präsentieren im sinne des jetzt
oder dem sinne dass früher oder später
das und im ziel des zugleich habe ihn
doch bestimmten relationen das internet
ist nicht anything goes das internet ist
muss ein wirrer haufen von information
so denkt man es vielleicht manchmal
anders
organisiert nach einer bestimmten logik
die logik würde ich eben sagen ist nicht
mehr primär raum zeitlich zu verstehen
ich gebe beispiel dieses jetzt spielt im
internet deswegen nicht mehr so eine
große rolle wohl es sicherlich auch
dieses jetzt moment gibt es möchte ich
gar nicht bestreiten weil eben alles
dokumentiert wird auch eben jetzt zum
beispiel diese vorlieb sei jetzt wäre im
internet das stichwort live wenn ich als
eine live übertragen wurde aber da ja
alles aufgezeichnet werden kann da ich
dann immer wieder im nachhinein springen
kann vorher zurück
spielt es immer eine geringere geboten
genauso auch mit anderen
dingen im virtuellen raum ich gebe es
noch ein paar weitere beispiel ich nenne
sie jetzt die chronologie der
digitalität kronos zeit topos raum
virtuelle digitale realitäten
abstrahieren von der zeitlichen
sukzession und auch der physisch
physikalisch räumlichen lokalisation
also ich kann nicht mehr sagen dieses
virtuelle buch ist jetzt hier irgendwie
an dieser koordinate im physischen raum
hier auf dieser welt kugel an diesen
koordinaten punkte das würde glaube ich
der sache nicht ganz gerecht naja das
internet lässt eine solche
lokalisation nicht mehr zu weil ja alles
miteinander in verbindung besteht also
es ist eher die vernetzung als die
lokalisation die im internet eine rolle
spielt anstelle der sukzession um
lokalisation tritt die relation die
ersetzt gewissermaßen die wesentliche
beschreibung dimension von digitalen
realität die relation ich gebe noch ein
beispiel ein physisches lexikon was
sagen wir mal aus dem jahr
1990 stammt und bei mir im regal steht
hier diese adressen und diesem punkt im
physischen raum ist es physikalisch
ausgedehnt das buch wird das nimmt einen
raum ein
und ich habe wie gebet ja auch lange
darüber diskutiert was ja auch irgendwie
eine enzyklopädie ist hat ganz
verschiedene eigenschaften haben wir in
dieser sitzung über die app is
technologie genau behandelt sowas ist
jetzt der unterschied zwischen diesen
beiden formen von lexika in raum
zeitlicher hinsicht
wikipedia steht damit im regal und es
veraltet auch nicht nach 30 jahren also
ich will damit sagen dieses physische
lexikon das veraltet irgendwie in seiner
form
veraltet sowohl was den einband und
diese körperliche seite anbelangt ist
veraltet aber auch in hinsicht auf die
informationen die darin enthalten ist
die natürlich immer auch gebunden ist an
das medium der gedruckten schrift hatte
das physische lexikon ist ein medium was
auf der gedruckten schrift passiert und
die medialität des internets die
medialität von wikipedia ist eine völlig
andere art ich gehe so weit und sage
wikipedia ist gar kein medium wikipedia
wäre gar nicht angemessen als medium zu
verstehen ich gehe vielleicht sogar so
weit dass sagt wikipedia ist selbst ein
latenter handlungsraum könnte man unter
umständen sagen ob es eine handlung des
raumes möchte ich noch ein bisschen
offen lassen aber gemobbt wird das kind
aber die tatsache dass wikipedia eine
freie enzyklopädie genannt wird dieser
dieses begriffs frei deutet darauf hin
dass es hier mit partizipation zu tun
hat und partizipation ist natürlich ein
ganz stark aktivistische praktisch
handlungsfähiges moment was in den
physischen lexikon keine rolle spielt
ein physisches lexikon als
kollaboratives lexikon zu konzipieren
ist extrem schwierig ja dann muss ich
mich regelmäßig treffen mit mit autorin
mit autoren und das nächste konvents
einmal gedruckt ist dann ist es gedruckt
dann muss ich eine zweite auflage beim
nach einiger zeit das kostet viel geld
viel aufwand viel papier und so weiter
und so fort wikipedia ist fluide könnte
man sagen es ist insofern fluide als es
permanent am wachsen ist also sie
permanent macht den wissenstand aus
richtig die frage inwiefern die qualität
von wikipedia einem physischen
traditionellen lexikon entspricht ist
eine andere frage ich glaube aber dass
diese frage gewesen damit zu tun hat
dass wikipedia ein kollaboratives
virtuelles kollaboratives phänomens war
es natürlich kann auch irgendwie viel
stärker ethische probleme ins zentrum
steht nämlich ethische probleme da
hingehen ob diese informationen darauf
verbreitet wird ob die tendenziöse ob da
irgendwelche interessen dahinter stehen
die nur eigennützig sind die neben nicht
im dienste der allgemeinheit stehen wir
sehen durch diese vernetzung im
virtuellen raum bekommt wikipedia eine
praktische dimension das ist beim
physischen lexikon so nicht der fall
wikipedia steht nicht im regal bei mir
und veraltet nicht nach 30 jahren jetzt
habe ich ihn frage zeigt gemacht also
ich glaube eben das
wikipedia immer up to date gehalten wird
ob das jetzt so von dieser qualität ist
wie ein physisches lexikon sei
dahingestellt aber ist wächst neben
immer mit es ist immer aktuell und es
hat auch nicht diese materielle seite
die darin besteht dass es irgendwann
auseinander fällt wie ein lexikon was
vielleicht 200 300 jahre alt ist je
nachdem wie es auch geben konzipiertes
aus welchem material
ich will damit nur sagen ein physisches
lexikon hat immer eine mein material
aspekt mitteilen und dieser material
aspekt tritt zurück bei einer virtuellen
realität wie wikipedia und dadurch tritt
eben auch die raum zeitliche
anfälligkeit und abhängigkeit diese
digital virtuellen realität immer mehr
zurück
das schalten eben ein interessanter
vergleich zu sein ich vertrete die these
dass wikipedia eine virtualisierung
eines vormals physikalischen lexikons
ist eine konsequente virtualisierung
loslösung von raum zeit nicht in
strukturen in blick auf eine vernetzung
auf eine renationalisierung im gegensatz
zur sukzession und organisation die zeit
wird im digitalen wirtschaftsraum zu
einem bloßen metadaten als einer
oberflächlichen eigentlich äußerlichen
informationen welches nicht die substanz
des wesen eines ding ist wirklich
betrifft wir haben gesehen auch eine
diskussion nach der letzten sitzung das
natürlich bei wikipedia verschiedene
zeitschichten quasi archäologisch zu
tage befördert werden können alte
versionen aber diese versionen sind im
grunde genommen nur
gewissermaßen mehr die daten
ich sehe dann den zeitstempel irgendwo
her aber die information eine solche
trägt dieses diesen zeitstempel nicht in
sich ja sie ist nicht veraltet sind
informationen die eben noch ne metall
information haben wann sie eben
entstanden sind das ist natürlich auch
wieder ein problem weil wir dann
irgendwie gar nicht mehr so genau wissen
was ist jetzt dünger was es eltern also
hier hier entstehen gewichtige probleme
im hinblick auf die zeitliche
orientierung und auch die räumliche
orientieren und das ist jetzt ein
wichtiger punkt der jetzt mein
verständnis von
virtueller raum zeit betrifft glaube
dass wir hier über den begriff der
relation und über den begriff der
orientierung sehr viel erklären können
der physische raum wird im digitalen
virtuellen raum zu einer komplexen
orientierungs relation ich will nicht
sagen dass die digitalen virtuellen raum
immer orientierung gestiftet ist das ist
nicht der fall in digitalen virtuellen
raum gibt es ziemlich viele etwas
ungeordnet was wird ganz klar aber wenn
wir jetzt und digitalen virtuellen raum
sprechen wollen ich habe ihn deswegen
anführungszeichen gestellt es ist eben
keine physische rama ich denke man kann
auch im übertragenen sinne von einem
virtuellen raum sprechen dann müssen wir
den nicht zu verstehen mit den
physischen raum im sinne der ausdehnung
der räumlichen ausdehnung die messbar
ist mit dem metermaß und eine extension
sonnen im sinne eine orientierungs
reaktion also virtuelle raum ist
orientierungs relation der nicht jetzt
fünf meter oder so hoch ist oder so der
kein volumen einnimmt sondern der eine
orientierungs ein orientierungs volumen
hat also orientierung ist ja in meinen
augen der das stichwort jetzt gibt es
seit einiger zeit und das ist auch noch
ein nachtrag zur letzten sitzung gibt es
hier verstärkte bemühungen den
virtuellen raum der hier jetzt nicht in
anführungszeichen geschrieben ist zu
verstehen was bedeutet das tobias hat
hier zu einem jahr 2016 ein sehr
interessantes buch geschrieben cyber
places philosophische annäherung an den
virtuellen ort kann ich sehr empfehlen
wirklich sehr verdienstvoll
paulisch fragt jetzt zum ersten mal
wirklich konsequent welche räumlichkeit
dem virtuellen raum zu grunde liegt ist
es jetzt eine metaphorische rede von
raum- oder steckt da mehr dahinter und
die methode wie sich jetzt der autor
dieses buches dem virtuellen raum
annähert ist eine phänomenologischen
also keine und begriffliche
ernährungssünden logische geschaut wie
zeigt sich virtuelle raum mir dem
subjekt in betrachten
meine methode die dieser vorlesung zu
grunde liegt ist nicht phänomenologische
begrifflich da fast wie sie vielleicht
schon gesehen habe mich für viele
begriffe ein die manchmal auch etwas
sehr sperrig sind noch habe ich habe
eine andere methode das soll aber nicht
heißen dass ich das nicht interessant
finde und hilfreich finde dass der autor
hier toten ich will jetzt mal einen
genaueren einblick thema was seite 13
während sich die orte der alltagswelt
angesichts der neuen medien einer
relativierung
möglicherweise sogar eine neue
bestimmung hinsichtlich ihrer
lebensweltlichen bedeutung ausgesetzt
sehen tritt in den virtuellen welten
eine neue art von orten zutage deren
einordnung zwischen illusion fiktion und
wirklichkeit noch nicht eindeutig
geklärt ist das finde ich jetzt sehr
hilfreich weil er eben sagt wir müssen
hier erst mal wirkliche begriffe prägen
um diesen neuen realitäten zu verstehen
er bringt hier auch den betrieb der
illusion fiktion und wirklichkeit ins
spiel anhand deren wir diese orte als
virtuelle phänomene näher bestimmen
müssen mir fehlt jetzt hier noch der
begriff der simulation den habe ich in
meiner übersicht über virtuelle realität
in den letzten vier letzten sitzung
genau erklärt aber ich finde es trotzdem
sehr sehr hilfreich müssen es vororten
reports gewissermaßen zwischen diesen
verstehen phänomen julischka
unterscheidet auch zwischen nord und
raum ort ist für ihn das wenige was
eigentlich phänomenologische
zugängliches der raum ist dahingehend
wie eine abstraktion also hier wird
immer vom konkreten zu den konkreten
orts erfahrung orts phänomenologie aus
die garantie ja vom raum unterscheidet
ich persönlich unterscheidet mich so
stark zwischen orten raum ich spreche
generell vom raum
und ich habe auch eine eigene theorie
des virtuellen raums die hier noch
präsentieren möchte die sich von allem
ist er unterscheidet aber ich finde es
trotzdem sehr wichtig dass man sich
jetzt jemand konkret dieser sache
technologisch also anschaulich auch
zuwendet und ich kann schreibt weiter
auf seite 36 das öffnen eines programms
die der sprache der computernutzer ist
nicht nur metaphorisch gemeint es ist
das öffnen eines zugangs bzw englisch
enter betreten eines fensters winter hin
zu einem virtuellen arbeitsplatz finde
ich sehr spannend also man erhalt der
alltagserfahrung der alltags
phänomenologie mal hier das ganze zu
beschreiben und ich persönlich würde ihm
dahingehend recht geben dass eine
virtuelle arbeitsplatz zum beispiel ein
desktop von windows
von apple wie auch immer dass der
durchaus eine bestimmte form aufweist
die man als ein ort bestimmen könnte nur
glaube ich dass diese örtlichkeit dort
von gänzlich anderer art ist als die
örtlichkeit oder räumlichkeit die wir
eben der physischen welt haben ich
glaube brauchen wir neue begriffe um sie
zu beschreiben und ich glaube es geht
nicht zu sehen anna logischer weise
müssen wirklich ganz neu
charakteristik haben uns hier
hinzunehmen meine these ist
orientierung orientierungs relation aber
wir wollen jetzt genauer schauen die
hollies karte zu machen er sagt der
titel cyber places vereint in anspruch
dieses buches in sicht den cyberspace
als technisch abstrakt virtuellen raum
aus der perspektive der orts
phänomenologie zu betreiben und darin
orts phänomene zu beschreiten die
phänologie
beschreibt immer
realität sie wertet mich zu stark sie
will ihr wissen wie es auf uns wird
wieder verordnung jetzt pünktlichkeit
verschiedene formen der räumlichen
wörtlichen begegnen begegnungsreise
erstmal die wieder vor ort wieder
verordnung bezeichnet eine zuordnung von
in der alltagswelt gegeben orts
konzepten im virtuellen das ist
vielleicht mit das wichtigste die wieder
verordnen so ist beispielsweise der
desktop als virtuelle arbeitsplatz und
erster anlaufpunkt nach dem start des
computers dem materiellen schreibtisch
als dem ort dem schreibtisch arbeiten
erledigt werden funktional nachempfunden
die wieder verordnung zeichnet sich
dadurch aus dass sie zur symbolischen
darstellung von computer funktionen auf
verbreitete orts konzepte zurückgreifen
obwohl auch eine andere technische
lösung möglich wäre hier finde ich jetzt
ganz spannend dass er statt es
funktional nachempfunden das scheint
hier wohl eine simulation zu sein eine
simulation
ich wäre hier ein bisschen vorsichtig es
gibt sicherlich symbolische
repräsentationen die so was wie ein
nachempfindung suggerieren zb
irgendwelchen symbole wie ein kleines e
mail also ein kleines brieflein was dann
für eine e mail gilt aber ich glaube das
ist doch schon ziemlich diese analogie
diese metapher dieses symbol ist doch
ziemlich ja ein ziemlich großen ferne
zur tatsächlichen e mail ich will damit
sagen unser e mail postfach zum beispiel
jetzt bei outlook oder bei google das
ist doch von gänzlich andere art als es
ein briefkasten ist der sich vor unserer
wohnung von zum haus befindet ja
ist eine virtualisierung darf ohne frage
aber eine wirkliche strukturelle
analogie
oder eine funktionale nachempfindung es
ist noch ein bisschen mehr würde ich
jetzt sagen die neue verordnung das ist
noch so ein punkt die möglichkeit neu
verortung und der wieder verortung im
virtuell entspricht zu gleichen
umgekehrter weise eine rückforderung in
der materiellen wirklichkeit als er
betrags jetzt nicht nur den weg von der
physischen realität der materialität zu
wirtschaften digital realität sind auch
den weg zurück diese rückbezug ergibt
sich notwendig aus dem materiellen
grundlage jeder virtualisierung als
einer form für technik und zeigt sich in
computern datenträgern und rechenzentren
der virtuelle ort ist in dieser hinsicht
doppelt verortet einerseits den
virtuellen andererseits immateriellen
technischen system denen erzeugen und
dabei selbst verortet zeit interessant
also der virtuelle ort zahl der
virtuelle desktop ist im virtuellen
verortet also in der digitalen
reibungslosen sphäre und auch
immateriellen technischen system nämlich
in der computer und so weiter
das kann man jetzt natürlich wieder
diskutieren und das markets für den
desktop vielleicht gelten den wir vor
uns haben aber wie sieht es jetzt mit
wikipedia aus wo ist jetzt wikipedia
verortet in dem server irgendwo
übersee wie sieht es aus mit den
teilnehmenden personen die dazu
beitragen mit nutzerinnen und nutzer wo
sind die verortet im system an ihrem ort
physischen ort hier kann man sich noch
viele fragen stellen aber ich finde es
sehr spannend diese drei halb von neue
verordnung wieder vor ort und rück vor
ort finde ich also sehr sehr spannend
aus phänomenologische sich
jetzt kann man sich natürlich noch
weitergehend die frage stellen wenn wir
jetzt diese frage der zeit
sup haben zu klären der virtuellen
realität da ist noch viel zu tun haben
vorläufig gestimmt haben wie können wir
auf basis von raum zeit logik der
virtuellen realität und der ontologie
der virtuelle realität
der digitalität man den angriffen meine
these ist eben dass wir erst dann wenn
wir diese frage geklärt haben wirklich
ethische aussagen darüber treffen können
oder jetzt beispiel sollen wir jetzt
hier das internet dient glaube das
internet ist das paradigma also der
beispiel das beispiel fällt um eine
solche analyse durchzuführen hier ist
wieder robert dreyfuss mein bezugspunkt
er hat ein sehr immer noch sehr
lesenswertes buch geschrieben den titel
die internet schon zweiter
auflage
das kann ich wirklich sehr empfehlen und
hier schreibt der folge müssen die
internet ist nutzers new technology
innovation in diesem youtube auf
türkische kino welchen one that brings
out the lessons of technology das heißt
das also es ist nicht nur ein
technisches phänomen oder eine
innovation sondern es ist ein
prototypisches ein paradigma tisches
technisches phänomen alles zeigt was
technologie überhaupt kann was
technologie im grunde auswahl ich würde
nicht so weit gehen
ich würde mir zu sagen es ist auf eine
technologie sondern ich würde sagen es
ist etwas was darüber hinaus geht es ist
eine virtuelle realität es ist nicht nur
eine technologie das ist etwas was auf
technologie energien sind der virtuellen
realität und es ist deswegen der
handlungsrahmen es ist natürlich auch
eine technologie ohne frage habe ich
glaube es wäre eine reduktion des
internets eine reduktionistischen
betrachtung wenn wir ist wo unter dem
gesichtspunkt der technologie betrachten
würden weiteres zitat wenn die ämter
cyberspace leave behind euro im monat im
sittertobel in bordells in der beiden
brüdern never before vejle britischen
teams
es ist seriös sommer von kruska
possibility to make sense allerdings
zuerst zu distinguished relevant von die
relevant konsens aus tierischer sex ist
fehlen wird es in der serie verloren und
auch niedrige dem maximum grip und wirte
gift aus einer sense of reality offenes
fördern die temperatur ist auf jenny
commitment in solo cyrus 18 ist mini
tornado
sein wird ist natürlich dreyfus ist
natürlich ein kritischer für die sofa
dreyfus betrachtet auch künstliche
intelligenz video gesehen haben immer
sehr kritisch und zwar warum weil er
sagt hier findet keine verkörperung der
stadt hier dieses in bonn
drei fonds vertritt das künstliche
intelligenz nur dann wirklich
intelligent sein kann wenn sie eine
körperliche seite hat wenn sie
relationen steht zu anderen dingen und
genauso auch über das internet das
internet kann nur dann wirkliche
bedeutung haben wenn wir hier auch
citroen im internet und das bestreitet
er spricht hier auch dass wir einen grip
on the world brauchen und der reality of
things das glaubt ihr nicht im internet
zu sehen ich bin hier anderem einen ich
glaube dass wir im internet sehr wohl
nicht vom körper sind nicht im pott sind
nein aber vernetzt sind ohne frage und
dass wir dieses im body went was
natürlich abhängig von unserer
räumlichen verfasste dass wir das nicht
nur simulieren sondern virtualisieren
können durch vernetzung und zwar durch
reibungslose zuletzt durch zeitliche
reibungslose vernetzung also hier möchte
ich bei wurst gesprächen er ist hier in
meinen augen zu kritisch obwohl er zu
recht auf viele probleme hinweist die
eben auch so was wie ernsthaftigkeit und
verbindlichkeit betreffen die im
internet höchst problematisch werden
das heißt wir können so meine thesen und
dann die ethische bedingung bedeutung
des internets angemessen bestimmen wenn
wir es als ein virtuellen handlungsraum
verstehen im internet sind nicht
verkörpern ohne frage aber im internet
sehen wir vernetzt also auf eine
besondere weise raum zeitlich und
deswegen können wir darin eben auch
handelt nur müssen wir handlung jetzt
auf eine ganz andere weise verstehen als
dieses verkörpern lichter hat das steht
außer frage das setzt allerdings zwei
bedingungen voraus um das internet als
virtuelle handlungsraum verstehen zu
koennen wir müssen virtuelle realität
stärker verstehen als nahtlose
simulation illusion der fiktion denn
diesen simulationen illusion fiktion
kommt nur eine sehr schwache ethische
bedeutung zu wenn sie jetzt alles was im
virtuellen raum sicherheiten oder im
internet wenn sie da nur sagen dass
diese simulation oder eine illusion dann
haben sie eigentlich gar kein grund das
unter einem ethischen gesichtspunkten zu
betrachten sie könnten nur sagen dass
das internet eine simulation ist es
ethisch problematisch dass hier so viel
mit illusionen gemacht wird ist
problematisch aber wenn sie das sagen
dann gestehen sie eigentlich bereits zu
dass das illusion erzeugen auf eine
virtuelle handlung beruht als die
illusion ist dann nicht das was sie
eigentlich kritisieren sondern dass die
illusion eingesetzt wird von akteuren
akteuren im virtuellen raum dh das
setzen sie eigentlich schon zu grunde
das internet keine bloße illusion ist
das heißt wir müssen es internet viel
stärker verstehen wenn wir ästhetisch
wirklich angemessen behandelt wollen und
wir müssen geben vor dem hintergrund des
internets als virtuelle handlungsraum
genauer bestimmt was virtuelle
handlungen sind
nicht nur irgendwelche illusionen sind
und wir müssen diese virtuellen handlung
insbesondere unter der raumzeit logik
virtuelle realität verstehen so glaube
ich können wir nur das internet als ein
virtueller handelsraum politisch
angemessen näher charakterisieren und
das will ich jetzt mal in folge und ganz
grob mal versuchen zu tun ich gebe es
noch ein paar virtuelle digitale
handlungsräume das sind soziale
plattformen und kanäle zb facebook
twitter youtube wir könnten uns auch
frage ob die gibt ja auch eine soziale
plattform ist es ist sieht auch aber
nicht primär
facebook ist mit sicherheit ein
virtueller handlungs frauen es ist
vielleicht nicht der größte
handlungsraum nicht der beste
handlungsraum aber dort finden auch
handlung statt das heißt soziale
plattform sind keine bloße medien die
wir rezitieren oder die information
vermitteln so kann man natürlich
facebook lesen dass hier nur
informationsaustausch stattfindet aber
auch der austausch von informationen ist
ja eine handlung die ethisch bewertet
werden kann es geht nicht nur um die
informationen die sich darin befinden es
geht darum wie wir diese information in
dem virtuellen handlungsraum einspeisen
wie wir damit umgehen
das heißt wir agieren darin und wir
rezipieren nicht nur das stellt
natürlich die frage nach der virtuellen
handlung was ist eine der anklamer
virtuelle handlung sind relation ali sie
röhren von
informationen besorgt damit meine ich
der virtuelle raum so habe ich ja
bestimmt ist ein orientierungs raum also
ein relations' geflecht zur orientierung
virtuelle handlung sind demnach
her stellungen produktionen von
relationen im virtuellen raum die
informationen ihre bedeutung betreffen
und diese relation ali sierung also
diese verknüpfung von informationen das
ist unsere aktivität den virtuellen
handlungsraum wir verknüpfen
informationen miteinander beziehen uns
auf information die speisen hat
informationen ein aber dieses einspeisen
bedeutet immer dass wir bereits
bestehende informationen mit neuen
informationen verknüpfen diese art der
verknüpfung die erzeugt auch eine
räumlichkeit und natürlich auch eine
zurechenbarkeit das kann nämlich in eine
moralische problematischeren eine
moralisch gute richtung gehen diese
relation zieren das ist mein augen
blickte kernpunkt von virtuelle
handlungen also diese relation ali
sierung und dieses erschaffen von
virtuellen räumen als ich will damit
sagen wir existieren nicht einfach nur
virtuellen raum
diese travel als gesetzt in diesem raum
sollen wir erzeugen diesen virtuellen
raum auch mit wir treiben diesen raum
weiter wie erweitern ihn oder wir
verengen ihn auch und das kann jeder
damit zusammenhängen wie wir diese
relational inszenierung vorher also wie
wir informationen miteinander
verknüpften ob wir diese ordnung in
einem produktiven sinne stärken oder ob
wir die ordnung schwächen ich gebe jetzt
mal ein beispiel für eine
problematische unmoralische handeln
internet das wäre in meinen augen eine
handlung die
falschinformation einspeist die also
eine renationalisierung vornimmt von
informationen die aber in auf eine
falsche richtung in einen raum eröffnet
nämlich zum beispiel ein verschwörungs
frau oder eine ideologie eine ideologie
ja das sind alles relation ali sierung
das sind eröffnungen von handlungsräume
von räumen die aber zu nicht zu einer
größeren orientierung berühren sonst
eine desorientierung oder sogar noch zu
einer radikalisierung
das heißt hier werden rahmenbedingungen
entworfen die sich
produktiv günstig oder destruktiv
auswirken können auf andere wird für den
mit seiner nutzer
weiteres beispiel fein
problematischen virtuellen handlungsraum
für eine virtuelle behandlung die
problematisch ist dass david wir hatten
darauf schon
bezug genommen einer vergangenen sitzung
dass das ist für mich ein paradefall von
einer problematischen
nicht nur handlung virtuellen haben uns
von einem problematischen raum warum
wollte ich diese orientierungs raum
gänzlich abkapselt dies orientierungs
raum der will versicht existieren und
sich nicht an die generelle tendenz
ich hab's die transzendente tendenz des
internets halten die immer wieder
weitere informationen in beziehung setzt
und in ihrem verhältnis klärt also der
dass die sich abkapseln da wird ein
gegen raum zur grundstruktur des
virtuell handlungsraum des internets
erzeugt der praktisch unter der decke da
irgendwie vor sich hin existieren möchte
und das halte ich auch eine
problematische entwicklung die auch
ethisch zu bewerten ist ja das heißt
hier kapseln wir uns ab und lasst uns
eigentlich gegen die tendenz des
internets gerichte die in meinen augen
positiv zu bewerten die tendenz alles
miteinander in verbindung zu setzen und
neue räume zu schaffen im sinne einer
orientierung ja dass ich sagen kann das
verhältnis zu gehen auf diese weise das
ist jetzt nicht eine solche bestimmung
dass man dann sagt das war vor dieser
sache oder das war nach dieser sache
sowohl die zum räumlicher zeit gehen
sind sondern es verhält sich so und so
von seiner bedeutung zu dieser sache das
kann natürlich auch beinhalten dass sie
eine zeit dimension mit dem spiel kommt
aber die zeitliche dimension ist
gegenüber der physischen dimensionen im
physischen raum eher von geringerer
bedeutung
das heißt raum und zeit gehen als
aspekte nicht wesentlich in die
virtuelle 1 1 zwar nur als metadaten sie
sind äußerlich diesen zu tun hat
und jetzt kann man natürlich auch
virtuelle handlung noch weiter
problematisieren wenn wir uns fragen
nach dem virtuellen akteure virtuellen
akteure ja wir müssen uns nach dem
virtuellen subjekt fragen das diesen
handlungen zu grunde
sie hat eben das aktuelle netz das
internet die möglichkeit die uns so im
physischen raum nicht so gut gegeben ist
sie es auch gegeben ohne frage aber im
internet verstärkt sich das ganze noch
weil wir hier nicht mehr auf unsere
physische existenz angewiesen wir sind
durch unsere physische existenz in raum
und zeit viel leichter identifizierbar
jemand mit so groß jemand bewegt sich so
und so unser weil die emission zu schwer
und hat diese äußeren merkmale diese
merkmale gibt es jetzt den virtuellen
raum nicht mehr dh das virtuelles objekt
kein anonymer und sollten immer form
existieren das ist als solches gar nicht
schlimm ich würde sagen es ist völlig
moralischen ordnung im virtuellen raum
anonymen pseudonym zu existieren wir
hatten das schon ein beispiel von
wikipedia ich finde sogar ganz wichtig
dass auf wikipedia die artikel von
anonymen pseudonym autorinnen autoren
verfasst werden um sie nämlich zu
schützen nun vielleicht auch so gerade
eine form von objektivität wieder zu
erzeugen
und auch sich eben unabhängig zu machen
von bestimmten sie geben halten aber wir
können das natürlich dann auch wieder im
negativen sinne gebrochen indem wir
andere
akteure täuschen und eben
desorientierung schaffen also wir müssen
darauf achten dass unsere anonymität und
subtilität im sinne der orientierungs
stiftung genutzt wird und nicht im sinne
der desorientierung was sich eben auch
dazu nutzen kann das ist jetzt nur ein
erstmaliger versuch gewesen diese
virtuelle handlung in ihren grundzügen
zu bestimmen auf basis der raumzeit
logik in der nächsten sitzung am 17 12
gehen wir auf den zweiten teil der
erdige digitalität ein und fragen uns in
wie vielen künstliche intelligenz
handeln kann hier ist jetzt es natürlich
auch voraus die raumzeit logik zu
berücksichtigen und hier müssen wir
natürlich auch klären inwiefern
künstliche intelligenz überhaupt als ein
subjekt betrachtet werden kann in der
darauffolgenden sitzung im neuen jahr
dann allerdings erst wieder werden wir
uns dann beschäftigen mit der frage ob
es eine generelle
der digitalität geben kann und wie die
auszusehen hat hier wollen wir auch
schauen auf die digitale
der europäischen union auf verschiedene
gesetze oder formen die sie dort dann
etabliert haben und schauen ob es zum
beispiel ein recht auf vergessen werden
im digitalen raum geben soll oder nicht
diese frage stellen wir uns dann ganz
zum schluss unsere dreiteiligen
befassung mit der ewige digitalität ja
jetzt sage ich ihnen vielmals für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und freue mich auf die
diskussion